und reif ich muss sagen ich hatte ein
wirklich ist déjà vu alleine dieses
setting also wir sehen den
bundesgesundheitsminister den lkw vize
und beide eben wieder in der bpk dieses
setting das war nicht zufällig gewesen
nein das war nicht zufällig karl
lauterbach doch direkt an an den
krisenmodus zu höchsten corona zeiten
freitags die aktuellen zahlen damals mit
lothar wieler der ist gerade im urlaub
deshalb jetzt der 14 und er geht genau
auf diesem drama modus wieder ein und
wenn man genau hinhört kommen etliche
maßnahmen die erst noch absprechen muss
die er plant sehr windig also das drama
der inszenierung passt in keinem börse
zum zum wirklichen zur ernst der lage
die er dort beschreibt dabei befinden
wir uns ja gerade im sommer so schöne
temperaturen draußen die sind so ein
bisschen sorgenfrei gerade vor allem
nach dieser ganzen corona panik der
letzten monate der letzten jahre muss
man ja auch schon sagen lasst uns mal
ganz kurz auf die krassesten aussagen
von karl lauterbach auch schon er hat
gesagt dass freiwillige masken tragen
das muss dazu gehören zu unserer
normalität nervt mich eigentlich anders
herum sagen auch genau aber diese
sommerliche
gefühlswelt die möchte er glaube ich
direkt zerstören das ist eigentlich
genau das wovor er warnt diese
leichtigkeit das darf nicht sein ist
immer schon derjenige gewesen der
gewarnt hat und selbst wenn jetzt die
hospitalisierung zahlen nicht so
dramatisch sind
möchte er eben in diese leichtigkeit ein
paar sätzen das ist schon recht gezielt
gemacht und dass das schwierige daran
ist dass es eigentlich eben gerade nicht
zur normalität werden soll masken zu
tragen sondern es soll nur dann genutzt
werden wenn es wirklich etwas abzuwehren
gilt das ist die grundlegende
philosophie frage die sich da immer
stellt bei derart beim alarmismus von
herrn lauterbach das ist schon sehr sehr
ärgerlich man hat nicht den eindruck
dass er daran arbeitet eben das masken
tragen zu verhindern sondern sich
sozusagen mit leidenschaft in die
pandemie stürzt wir haben allerdings
ampel regierung da gibt zum beispiel
auch noch eine fdp die ja offenkundig
eher nicht für solche maßnahmen ist
glaubst du dass karl lauterbach mit
solchen plänen überhaupt durchkommen
wird es wird etliches an der fdp
scheitern und ich sagen dazu es wird
zurecht und glücklicherweise schaltern
es ist auch eigentlich schlechter stil
sich hier vor die bundespressekonferenz
zu setzen und anzukündigen dass er erst
noch mit seinem amtskollegen marco
buschmann dem justizminister darüber
sprechen müssen wird was an reformen im
infektions gesetz wirklich durchkommen
das macht man vorher und dann verkündet
man oder man kündigt an welche ideen man
hat aber es kann nicht sein dass man
sozusagen vorab irgendwelche
ankündigungen macht von denen auch dann
der bürger ja gar nicht weiß kommen die
oder ist es jetzt einfach mal so eine
idee dann sagt karl lauterbach ja also
er wäre mit der vierten impfungen
großzügig was ist das jetzt also ist das
jetzt irgendwie ein koch tipp vom
gesundheitsminister es gibt eine stiko
empfehlung gesagt bedrohte vor erkrankte
menschen über 60 sollten sich die vierte
impfung geben lassen und dann kommt der
gesundheitsminister und sagt irgendwie
aus der fülle seiner lebenserfahrung
heraus ja ich wäre da großzügig das
finde ich einen stil der es
unverantwortlich es geht hier um die
gesundheit der menschen und da kann man
sehr viel ernsthaftigkeit klarheit aber
eben auch wirklich fakten weil sie jetzt
erwarten schreibt schuler dankeschön für
eine ganz klare einschätzung